there was a first time that I ever saw  his doctor zhivago and I it was very  funny because most of the film we saw in  Vietnam who is in deaf in French so I  always thought oh ma cherie was French  and then I remember seeing some other  film like we have clean Eastwood or  Steve McQueen his old up in French and  we had a really great big theatre  correct cinema in Vietnam and we it's  always a big deal to go there because  it's like a family kind of thing we all  all the kids getting ready and getting  to the theater we all run into the front  because we think we can see it much  better and we'll see closer we can get  into more of the scene kind of thing  he's always very exciting to go see a  film when we were kids